- Le décor a beau être
enchanteur, la cible
plutôt ambitieuse...
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre d
- C'est un plan qui répond
aux besoins des Canadiens.
de l'atteindze1reshe
encore un peu floue.
Car pour réduire ses émissions
de 730 à 443 mégatonnes
en 8 ans, le gouvernement
Trudeau doit s'attaquer aux
secteurs les plus polluants,
entre autres celui du pétrole
et du gaz, responsable de 26 %
des émissions au pays.
Mais Ottawa ne donne pas
d'échéancier pour un éventuel
plafond d'émissions.
Il doit d'abord discuter
avec l'industrie.
- On en demande énormément
à l'industrie pétrolière.
- Faux, répond l'opposition
bloquiste.
KRISTINA MICHAUD, députée, BQ,
Avignon-La Mitis-Matane
- Mais un plan de réduction qui
ne nous permet pas de plafonner
la production, ou du moins(-de s
un avenir rapproché, bien, ce
n'est pas tout à fait crédible.
- D'ailleurs, même si le Canada
s'est doté d'une projection
globale de 40 % de réduction,
elle n'est que de 31 % pour
le secteur pétrolier et gazier.
STEVEN GUILBEAULT, ministre féd.
Environnement et Chang. climat.
- La rapidité avec laquelle
on peut déployer des mesures,
que ce soit des mesures
technologiques, font en sorte
qu'on ne pouvait pas simplement
prendre un chiffre et dire :
ça va être le même chiffre
pour tout le monde.
CAROLINE BROUILLETTE,
environnementaliste
on climatique, c'est
un effort d'équipe, et c'est
décevant de constater que
plusieurs joueurs soient restés
sur le banc de touche, notamment
le secteur pétrolier et gazier.t
de signer une entente avec
les libéraux, se dit déçu
du plan et promet de faire
pression sur le gouvernement.
JAGMEET SINGH,
chef, Nouveau Parti démocratique
- On a besoin de plus d'actions,
des actions plus fortes.
- Autre grand secteur polluant :
les transports, qui constituent
25 % des émissions
Le gouvernement fédéral
promet que d'ici 2030, 60 %
des voitures vendues au pays
seront des véhicules propres.
Mais il restera encore bien
des voitures à essence sur
nos routes, croit cet expert.
PIERRE-OLIVIER PINEAU, Chaire de
gest. se'énergie, HEC
- Le parc automobile qu'on a
aujourd'hui, c'est un parc
automobile essentiellement
composé de camions légers
et qui est en croissance.
Et ce sont des véhicules qui,
dans une large mesure, vont
encore être là dans huit ans.
- Malgré ces critiques,
plusieurs experts notent que
la feuille de route présentée
par le gouvernement Trudeau
reste plus complète et détaillée
qu'elle ne l'a été dans le
passé. Mais est-ce que ce plan
sera suffisant pour atteindre
nos cibles d'ici 2030?
Difficile à dire.
Ici Laurence Martin,
Radio-Canada, Ott